-Welcome back.
-Thank you so much.
-Welcome back, welcome back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
It means a lot to me.
Thank you so much for coming.
You know I love you and you've
been a great guest on the show.
And I was a little late to the
party by reading "Greenlights"
and I called you up,
I think it was last year.
And I said, "Hey, dude,
I really love 'Greenlights.'
Congratulations. This is great."
And you go, "It's been out
two years," and I go --
-You got to.
-But I got --
It is unbelievable. And I told
you the story already,
so I don't want to bore you.
But I read it and I loved it.
I couldn't put it down.
And then my friend said,
"Did you do the audible book?"
I go, "No, I read it."
And they go,
"Yeah, you got to do the audible
because it's Matthew talking,
reading the book."
I go, "You're kidding me."
So I spent probably
24 hours of my life
with you
and you didn't know about it,
and it was worth every second.
-We did alright?
-I loved it so much.
Can you say alright anymore?
-Oh, I can say alright.
-Okay, good. I just don't know.
-People ask me all the time.
"Do you get tired of that?"
I said, "No.
It's the first three words
I ever said on film 32 years ago
when it precedes me.
I thought I might just
have a one-night hobby.
It turned into a career.
Please say it."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, that story
is a great story.
It's in this book, by the way,
and congrats on the success.
I think it was number one
for 98 weeks or something.
Almost 100 weeks.
-Moving up on 100. Yeah.
I had no idea that it was
going to hit the main vein
like it did and has,
but I've enjoyed
the conversations
with everybody around the world
that I've run into
that have told me
how that book has affected them.
So thank you.
It's my pleasure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you get nervous
when you think about
maybe doing a book like this?
Do you go like, "I don't know
if I want to be this person,
I want to be this honest?"
-Right.
-Do publicists get involved
and they go, "Matthew, do not --
don't tell that story."
-No, when I went to write it --
I mean, look,
I didn't ask permission
about what stories
to put on there,
although in post,
I don't know --
my publicist is out there.
I think we did alright.
I told personal stories,
but I tried to tell them
in a way that anyone -- age,
female, male, whatever --
could understand them
and see themselves in my story.
And that's been the main thing
I've heard from people
around the world going,
"Hey, I've been
in that scenario
and I chose to do something
different than you did.
I'm going to try what you did"
or "I've been in that scenario
and I screwed up like you did,
McConaughey."
You know? So they're seeing me
and them.
-And talking about your mom
and dad and all that stuff.
But they're so interesting
and it's so honest in here.
And I go, "Oh, that's real."
This book is so real
and I love that.
And then kind of you
could see
the seeds of "Just Because" in
"Greenlights"
because this tree house here,
there's a story behind
this tree house.
-I had a 13-story tree house
that I write about
in "Greenlights" that I found
a hardware construction store
out in the middle of the woods,
and I came across it,
waited till they got off work,
got the wire cutters,
cut through the fence
and snuck through
and started stealing lumber
and would take it
to this one big Ponderosa pine
in the backwoods where I lived.
And I had all the wood
to make the most incredible
tree house in the world.
I made a 13-story tree house
over an entire summer.
And that's why
that's on the cover.
A tree house,
I think, is a symbol
for all of us in our youth.
It's the first place for me
where I got to go
and have my private thoughts,
write down my private things,
have my things that I was like,
"No one else can see that
if I don't want them to.
Only people in my tree house is
who I invite to my tree house."
So that's what "Just Because"
it's on the cover.
-And so you write this
and you go,
"Okay, let's give it a shot.
I'll release
this children's book."
Did you ever think you would
ever write a children's book?
I mean, you're a great dad.
-Ehhh.
I never really thought about it.
Look, this came to me
in a little ditty of a dream
one night, and I woke up at 2:30
with this little hook.
You know, just because
they threw the dog
don't mean that it stuck,
da-da-da.
Just because I got skills
don't mean there is no luck.
And I woke up
and it was a good dream.
And as you do in good dreams,
you don't want them to end.
You try to keep the rhythm
of the thought, right?
I get up and I write...
[ Scatting ]
And I write all this stuff down.
I write about 200 couplets,
30 of which
made it into this version
'cause this is a younger --
younger person version.
And I looked at and I
found those 30. I was like,
"Hey, this is some stuff that
my children are going through.
This is some stuff that I hear
my kids' friends talking about
they're going though. This is
some stuff that I hear parents
or their friends of mine saying,
'My kids are going through
this.'"
So that's what's in the book.
-I dig it, man. I love it.
This is so up my alley.
This is like -- Even if I didn't
have kids, I would have this.
-Right on.
-It really is.
It's one of those, like,
kind of "Giving Tree"
kind of ideas for me where I go,
"I want to remind myself
of all these things."
What do your kids think
of the book?
-The kids dig it.
Look, look, I've got --
My daughter is very visual.
She loves the illustrations,
which Renée Kurilla did,
who's in the audience today.
-Fantastic illustrations.
-Yeah.
-Great job. So cute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My eldest and I have talked
about similar scenarios
that he's going through now
in his teenage years.
My youngest is still sort of
holding out to tell me
if he likes it or not,
but that's just
kind of his character.
[ Laughter ]
-I like the dedication
at the end of the book there.
Would you mind reading it?
-What's it say?
"To my kids, your kids,
and the kid in all of us,
we're all as young
as we're ever going to be.
So let's just keep learning.
McConaughey." Yeah.
-That's it. That's exactly it.
-Isn't that true?
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're a young as we're
ever going to be right now.
-That's so true.
-Oh, just got older.
-We just --
-Oh, we just got older.
-Yeah, exactly.
Also, by the way,
I'm happy
you're here in New York City
'cause last time you were here,
you went to
the Empire State Building.
-Yes.
-To talk about "Just Because."
Right?
-This was wild.
-And then they surprise you.
I love this.
What was going
through your head?
You were there with your wife.
-So, I didn't even know I was
in the Empire State Building.
I'm doing the press tour
for the book.
I'm pointing to shoot.
"Tell me where to go.
My head's down.
Tell me who to talk to."
And I walk in this building.
I think I'm going to go
into another interview.
There's my wife with
a whole bunch of cameramen
and camerawomen and my journal,
and she says, "Read this."
And I'm like, "What's going on?"
And I read it and it says,
"I wrote 'Greenlights'
three years ago.
Little did I know
that we'd be coming up on
100 weeks
on the best-seller list.
And congratulations to that.'
The Empire State Building
is lighting itself
green tonight."
And I was like...
They're like,
"Yeah, you're in it."
And we went upstairs and...
-Look at this.
-Pulled the lever
and this turned on green
that night in New York City
for a doggone...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-That's one of those things
that's like on your bucket list,
but you don't even know
to put it on your bucket list.
-That's so cool. I'm so happy.
But congrats on both books,
"Greenlights" and "Just Because"
right here right now,
everybody, pick it up
wherever books are sold.
We're going to do something fun
with the book
and Matthew McConaughey,
everybody, come on back.